park
an oasis of green in the heart of the
city
it runs along an old rail line that once
ran south from potsdamer platz
it covers an area totaling 26 000 square
meters
that means there's lots of room for all
kinds of activities
it's so central i can get here from but
in no time
i like the wide variety of playgrounds
it's such a wonderful place for older
people to come for a stroll but young
people too
you can still see some of the old tracks
you can only guess at what used to go on
here
old tracks that are overgrown
these relics of pre-war days were
deliberately left in place and
integrated into the park
a century ago this was europe's largest
railway complex consisting of the amhata
station and a freight depot
the junction of all these lines was
called gleiss drayek or triangle of
rails
the rail lines and stations were
completely destroyed in the second world
war the area became part of west berlin
but the rights to use the railway
facilities went to east germany which
left the property unused
in the 1960s locals started pushing to
have the area around kleistraeck
developed one of them was klaus trapman
now for their
it was actually fenced off
but starting in the 60s and 70s
little groups of nature lovers started
coming here
after germany was reunified the berlin
senate considered putting a highway
through gleistraeck but a citizens
initiative proposed turning it into a
park in 2004 they got their way
citizens city planners and architects
work together to design a metropolitan
park
its railway history still can be
experienced in many places
the ideas and needs of ordinary
berliners were taken into consideration
when creating the park
that's why the park includes a 1300
square meter skatepark developed in
consultation with active skaters
gleistraeck park once the largest
railway complex in europe
it's now a place of recreation and
relaxation
an example of how something special can
rise out of ruins